do you still remember all the lyrics to
that song like that
no guys I like no I don't listen to what
you may think I listen to I'm all over
the map
do you ever go back nostalgic only
nostalgic moments don't really go back
to our like Hangu mr. Cooper or things
before that because I can't remember it
but eggs after that I kind of do
something like maybe I can say it like
this you're you're at home and you're
you wash your floors all day long that's
all you do is wash George Washington
where's Marshall horse and you know
everybody comes in oh my goodness it's
so beautiful thank you thinking you're
like oh I know any good couch thank you
you can see them for but fans can't get
enough in fact many are still clamoring
for a Cheetah Girls reboot or reunion
[Applause]
[Music]
so could it happen I need to talk to the
girls first because we need to we need
to curate advancer this can go sideways
nobody won't listen I'm down with a
dream whenever agents don't do them down
I will work with Adrian for the rest of
my life she's awesome
I love everybody in their own ways you
know I'm saying it's just listen real
girl groups have their moments the
message of the Cheetah Girl movement is
the most beautiful thing I think I've
ever been a part of and the stories that
can come out and have come out have
shaped and molded many generations which
is and yes how I would love to be a part
of that brand in it but it needs to be
genuine you know I mean you we all have
to be there and you know it was my bad
for not being in the fourth one that was
my bad but you know who knows hey after
Corona anything is possible
I mean you're you're so and this is just
my thoughts of you I just feel like
you're so Zen and you're such a kind of
obscure and I feel like you have the
power to heal every point in to get
everybody in a room to be like let's go
nice in a greater power of table that
table better have some Krispy Kremes in
the middle of it girl I can get you
[Laughter]
I mean but have you thought about what
it would take to make something like
that happen again
do you I haven't really thought about it
to be honest with you and working on
radios home on my music or many other
ventures I casi Adrian at the women's
March whose amazing idea mister like I
said life is soul world every book can
happen but it will take all of us or of
us to come together and I know cheetah
babies are happening
Adrian I mean he he has her beautiful
girl and now Serena come on a junior
technically in line your next right
where was bubbles let's say bubbles has
her own independent record label a woman
for now Raven is focusing on a different
type of music her own and it's a big
departure from her pop past she just
released a new single called space truck
[Music]
with the song no idea what it looks like
I could answer that question for this is
my time or Raven Symone because it was
such a it was such a formulaic product
that I could be like yeah but I haven't
done music like this in 29 years almost
a year
I was busy during that time this kind of
music didn't fit the look that was being
projected that was being curated and
mixed up and packaged for those out
there and when I took over my career
fully and ups and downs and back and
forth sputter behind the scenes and
mostly because I turned 34 34 30 as I
continue to grow and read female or male
notes your mind changes those timeframes
massive changes and imagine a mind that
has been entertaining others for so very
long and I know there are inner workings
of a lot of things that our business
oriented and have nothing to do with
normal childhood
[Laughter]
everyday to get into the chair to look
like Raven Baxter takes almost two hours
turkey that grew and and I loved every
minute of it and it's showing me who I
am and helping me marinate in vital
juices and create something that is
space truck / and presence I mean if if
you had to describe miss Raven it what
would you say I would say she's a 34
year old human who has had many
successes in her life and who was able
to stand in front of you and be
comfortable in her own skin finally not
just from a song from her last album
what does that let's say you since you
were younger
you've been it surely or even it surely
surely your cheerleader but you've
always just wanted to go and be in drama
no one would let you because there's
these ideals and social constructs you
need to uphold and one day you say you
go so I'm with this music I am releasing
what I've known to be how to act in
public versus what was going on my mind
really when I was saying I guess people
like I'm going to be here right now
before but you'll never say you know you
mean like that type of thing so the pain
that I'm talking about it's just my
thoughts throughout all of the years of
don't know me yet like I'm just here
trying to maneuver in this weird world
and you don't know me I mean without
getting like 2g but how painful was it
for you no pun intended
how people I mean is mind-altering it's
um it's therapy worthy it's
communication with people closest to you
ending in tears and hugs and joy but
it's shedding I'm Multi Raven yeah I'm
not going to talk about my pain in
general just to be honest with you and I
know that's no oh let me feel their that
story but I'm not good at that so you
gotta listen to my music to feel it
[Music]